foreign
Stephen A Smith has a new book out it's
called straight shooter and it is an
inspiring Memoir of his rise to fame his
success in sports media and even how he
overcame a learning disability and a
very rough childhood and get this there
is a premier live signing at 10 p.m
right after the show tonight I'll be
moderating and interviewing Stephen A
it's at Stephen go backwards I can't see
Stephen a smithbook.com uh it's right
after the show about five minutes after
ten uh Eastern now here is the author's
straight shooter A Memoir of Second
Chances and first takes
this is a
when you were on my radio show for an
hour last week in studio with me it was
a hard hour for me because we've been
friends a long time
we never got this deep
this is a Triumph to tragedy book I had
no idea about the pain that you went
through as a child left back in the
third grade had to go to summer school
left back completely in the fourth grade
how to redo the fourth grade
and you overheard a conversation your
dad was not and you describe it in your
own book not a particularly good man in
a lot of ways I'll let you describe it
yourself a conversation where you hear
your father describe you as being stupid
and I can't imagine how painful that was
um talk about it
well he definitely said it he said that
uh the boy ain't smart he's just not
going to do anything with his life get
over it he told my mother that and I
heard him say it uh but I have to admit
to you that as painful as it was to hear
that uh combined with the laughter from
the kids in the on the Block just
minutes earlier uh it was an incredible
source of motivation because knowing
that my father felt that way about me
and he had such little faith in me I
believe that was the start of a level of
determination that I have never let go
of in my entire life a lot of times as
adults we take into account and we we
think about the effect things could have
on children
um and how lingering of effect it can be
but guess what it's not always negative
sometimes it can motivate you in a very
very positive way to exceed expectations
to make Liars out of out of doubters and
to excel to Heights unknown and unseen
and unimagined and that's exactly what I
believe I did you know and then you talk
about an incredible mother an incredible
sis your incredible sisters in this book
and they didn't call it at the time what
it was you had dyslexia and they
discovered and they taught you how to
read and then you tell the story in the
book about one teacher that brings your
mom in and says
um I hate to tell you this your son's
really really smart and not only is he
really smart he just if he's not
interested he's not gonna pay attention
you [ __ ] you find the thing he's most
interested in and he's going to be a
star
and look what happened yeah
I hate to say it I hate to admit it
publicly but you're a star
something like that but I'm thankful to
Mr Caravan to this very day uh that he
said that to my mother and to me uh
because it definitely elevated my
confidence to another level made me that
much more focused
um and it it helped me to find my
passion which was Sports because once I
read sports and watched Sports and
really really comprehend what was going
on it built my confidence in other areas
I'm reading news I'm reading politics
I'm reading current events I'm reading
you know a lot of different things that
I would never do you're yelling at me I
understand suddenly the comprehension
was yeah you sent me a text every day
tell me how wrong I am he told me how
wrong I am every day well not every day
no this is about close five days a week
football four or five days a week you're
wrong I'm working for you in the
ballpark you need help but that's what
I'm here for that's what I'm here for I
want to remind our audience uh this book
is phenomenal and it's a great book it's
tragedy to Triumph straight shooter
Stephen A Smith head over to Stephen A
smithbook.com there's going to be a live
signing it starts five minutes after the
show ends I'm going to be interviewing
Steven we'll give you more details uh so
that's all coming up hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else